hey guys P peppers here and this is a
candy crush jelly saga level 17
walkthrough with commentary 17 is one of
the first difficult beats Queen levels
so I'm gonna go ahead and talk about
some of the tips and try to beat her
while we can so we always want to make
specials that we can because that will
stun the Queen and give us an extra move
so we'll go there's nothing really going
on here so we'll go ahead and make one
under our color we got a pretty good
result there so just look around and see
if we can make another one
we can't on our side we can on her side
but that doesn't really help us at this
point so what I'm gonna do instead is go
ahead and make this red match because
that sets up for our next move we can
make a fish and break through this
licorice lock here I'm gonna go ahead
and do that and I'm gonna check up above
we have a rat candy match now it's on
her side but since it's touching our jam
as well it's gonna go ahead and spread
it so that's definitely a good move it's
done her again and if we can do that one
more time we're gonna get a super stun
so even though this is on her side I'm
gonna go ahead I was gonna make the the
fish but now that I think about it this
is gonna fall so I'm gonna go ahead and
do it with this one instead so so triple
stone now it says make a special move so
if you're new at the game you probably
haven't played the clean that much or
paid that much attention so yeah that
that's you know the kind of thing we
want to have happen and we have a couple
choices here where we can make a stripe
that'll be going down that would be good
but then we can also make a fish here
and then we can match it with this wrap
candy so
I kind of like the idea of making the
fish because I draw a little make
another match right after and whereas it
turns out we haven't have a chance to
make another stun move by making a
striped I'm gonna go ahead and do that
because I know that's gonna set all that
stuff off at the same time sweet alright
so we still have a super stun charge and
we have 45 out of 64 so we're almost
there
so we're basically like one big combo
away from taking over enough of the
board and I saw some people posting in
different places saying that the clean
sheets probably what you're seeing I
mean the best thing I can understand are
I can guess I got it would be that they
they're the Queen's get an extra moves
and they don't know why just like how we
can stun her with our specials so you
can do the same to us so that that's
where that comes from the Queen
definitely doesn't cheat she follows a
really strict and simple you know set of
rules and so if you see that she gets
extra moves it's because she made it
special and that always does that so
since we have the super stun I'm gonna
go ahead and make this match it's gonna
fire striped over to this fish but it's
also gonna give us this you can see the
how the outside is sparkling it's also
going to give us it's gonna set up a
little like explosion that's gonna cover
more of the board in our color as well
do that so we just are too short she's
probably got a couple back but all I
really need to do now is just finish it
off so you know that that's pretty much
all you need to know Queens a little
frustrating at first but you know trust
me the more you play the more you think
about planning things out for the you
know
the future most of the time making
specials especially we have a big board
like this is gonna be the key to making
it a lot easier because we get more
moves in a row and then you get those
super stuns where you get to get the
explosion always keep that stuff in mind
I'm gonna go ahead and add this to a a
guide but some more tips about playing
the Queen and I hope it helps and you'll
get past this level if you're stuck make
sure you like the video if you found
that helpful and subscribe to my channel
so that you can find more videos like
this as I put them out all the time
thanks